[Music]
Amanda Knox is back in Italy for the
first time since being acquitted of
murder eight years ago
cameras greeted the former exchange
student when she arrived yesterday for a
Criminal Justice conference she went
through multiple trials following the
2007 murder of her roommate the case
attracted global attention Seth Doane is
following her visit in Modena Italy
Seth what's the reaction been to her
return well Anthony we are here at the
conference in which she is taking part
and there is certainly a lot of support
for her here but her presence in Italy
has reignited a media firestorm and
according to the lawyer for the family
of the victim Meredith Kercher it has
reopened old wounds she was only in the
conference with her fiance for a few
minutes this morning before the glare
was too much an organiser telling us she
was traumatized by the media but Amanda
Knox knows cameras they trailed her for
years here though on this trip her first
back to Italy since 2011 she's appeared
shaken she's here to take part in a
conference hosted by the Italy Innocence
Project which frees those wrongly
imprisoned before coming to Italy she
posted pictures and published an essay
writing while on trial for a murder I
didn't commit my prosecutor painted me
as a sex crazed femme fatale and the
media profited for years by
sensationalizing an unjustified story
Knox originally from Seattle served four
years in an Italian prison for the
murder and sexual assault of her
roommate Meredith Kercher she left Italy
when she was acquitted in 2011 but later
was found guilty in absentia in a third
trial and was finally exonerated by
Italy's Supreme Court in 2015 Amanda
Knox said returning to Italy was either
a homecoming a deployment or madness I
guess it could be a homecoming
deployment and that Nesmith Miller is
the executive director of the Innocence
Project of Florida this is a place where
something really bad happened to her and
I think it's natural that there would be
some anxiety and worry about coming back
to this
in the SI NOx refers to herself as a
journalist and explains she's working on
a true-crime podcast which attempts to
rehumanize those thrusts into the media
spotlight NOx did return to the
conference a little bit later now
throughout the day since she arrived
here in Italy she has pretty much
successfully dodged the media but we do
know she is being followed by her own
personal videographer so we cannot
exclude the possibility that some of
this is being choreographed for her own
camera Toni Seth don't forests in Modena
Italy she seems to run from the cameras
but also there be attracted to Trek yes
I mean I can understand the push and
pull cos in a lot of ways when she was
on trial over and then Italy she kind of
lost control of her identity she her
name was everywhere but she didn't
really get to say anything now she's
trying to say something but she has to
deal with all of this still Thank You
Seth Doane